you co-founded the foundation for
individual rights and expression also
known as fire a legendary organization
that fights for the freedom of speech
for all Americans in our courtrooms on
our campuses and in our culture so let's
start with the big question what is
freedom of speech first of all the
organization when I co-founded it in
was called the foundation for individual
rights in education
it focused on
Free Speech issues on college campuses
in Academia
and only earlier this year did we decide
to expand our reach beyond the campuses
which is why the name although the
acronym fire remains it's now the
foundation for individual rights and
expression the EU is to be education the
e used to be education it's now
expression and we basically do a lot of
the cases the ACLU used to do the ACLU
now moorses the the progressive
organization rather than a civil
liberties organization
and um and we've taken the um the the
role of dealing with free speech in in
the society generally in and now this is
a particularly
um uh an era prone to censorship
um everybody thinks they're right and
that people who disagree with them
should not be able to voice their views
it's a very difficult period right now
both on campus and off campus
um it's about as as intolerant an era as
I can remember I'm going to be 81 May
10th I was born on Mother's Day 1942.
and I can't remember it being this bad I
was born during the McCarthy era
um
so that says a lot and um it sort of
reminds me of that
well let's start with that almost a
philosophical question a legal question
a human question what is this Freedom
that you care so much about that you
fought for so much freedom of speech it
is the most important right that
Americans have
it's not a coincidence
or an accident that it's named in the
First Amendment
to the Constitution
without it no Democratic Society can be
Democratic for long
and I'm an absolutist
that is
um I believe that for example people say
to me
but what about hate speech
well hate speech is much more important
than love speech and the reason is I'm
much more interested in knowing whom I
should not turn my back on
then I am interested in
figuring out who loves me or who likes
me
so hate speech is the most important in
my view and yet it's uh it's banned in
for example schools it's unbelievable
um kids are not schooled into
understanding the glory of the first
amendment when when schools say to them
they shouldn't say things that are going
to make somebody feel bad
um I mean the purpose of speech is to
express honest
views that people have and um so I
believe hate speech is as important as
love speech and my view is more
important
so it should be brought to the surface
rather than operate in Shadows
absolutely
absolutely what is the connection
between freedom of speech and freedom of
thought
well in a free Society
thoughts start on the brain and then
they come out the mouth
so there are different ends of the same
Spectrum
so to you the censorship of speech
eventually leads to a censorship of
thought of course censorship of the mode
by which other people know what you're
thinking so there's some aspect of our
society that is uh the thinking is done
collectively and without being able to
speak to each other we cannot do this
kind of collective ranking and out of
speed the theory is that ultimately out
of speech comes truth that isn't no
necessarily so
but I do think that when there's free
speech better decisions are made because
people put their views on the table in a
Frank accurate way and then those views
mixed together
and clash and out of that usually
comes the better the better decision
not always but usually more more often
than not but if somebody is not allowed
to be a you know sit at the table of
decision making
then the decision-making process is
poorer
um less robust
less diverse
and ultimately less successful
can you elaborate on the idea Free
Speech absolutism
so
hate speech
can be quite painful to quite a large
number of people does this worry you yep
living in a free Society
requires that you expose yourself to
some discomfort you call it pain
it's maybe emotional pain it's not
physical pain
um
but
it's uh it's the price we pay for living
in a free Society every so often we're
insulted
we're emotionally hurt
think of the alternative all the
alternatives are worse nobody ever
promised us a Rose Garden
we're lucky to be in a country that has
the First Amendment it's also the oh
it's the most diverse country in the
world
because of immigration
I mean my my
grandparents My Father's Side came over
from Russia on my mother's side came
over from Poland
I'm very happy that my grandparents came
in from Russia I would not want to be in
Russia today I'd probably be sharing a
cell with a Wall Street Journal reporter
um so um I'm thankful that they came in
and um this is a great country it's got
troubles right now but our country
doesn't and we've had before we had a
civil war we had segregation uh we had
the decimation of the Indians we're not
perfect
but it's the best place in the world for
somebody who values Liberty so you don't
think that hate speech can Empower large
groups
that uh
eventually lead to physical action to
physical harm to others no I don't I
think that that
um we have developed a culture in which
um it's understood that if you don't
like what you hear you you talk back
um you write
you write something um
we don't punch each other we insult each
other
um it's insulting great well I don't
know it's okay I guess that as a kid in
Brooklyn where I was born I was born and
raised in Bensonhurst we used to say
Sticks and Stones can break by bones but
names can never harm me and it's
absolutely true if what was true when I
was five is true and I'm I'm almost 81.
so I've lived a long time I've seen it
all
and I'm talking from experience as well
as Theory
it's what happens when you reach your
80s
I read that you had this line that you
cannot be protected from being called an
correct especially if you're an
well that's uh
but you don't have to be an to
be called an that's correct and
uh I think the internet has taught me
that well the internet is posed a
particular challenge to free speech
absolutist because of some of the stuff
that's on there is god-awful
but I have no different rule for freedom
of speech on the internet than I have uh
in newspapers or in lectures or in
classrooms or or conversations among
people what do you think about the
tension between freedom of speech and
freedom of reach as is uh kind of
sometimes termed so the internet really
challenges that aspect it allows the
space to become viral and spread very
quickly to a very large number of people
well you know we've had we've had
Revolutions in um
in in the modalities of communication if
you're all newspapers were the first
challenge
um radio and television
posed A new challenge
um the FCC tried
But ultimately gave up the attempt to
control
um obscenity for example
um and the Supreme Court has been pretty
close the one thing that liberal and
conservative Supreme Courts right now
we're in a conservative era due to Trump
nominations
um
during much of my life we were the
Warren Court it was uh William O Douglas
Brennan liberal Court
one thing they agree on is Free Speech
they don't agree on much else but they
do agree on free speech and I think the
reason is
that they recognize that well my group
is in the ascendance today but it may
not be tomorrow and I want to have
objective clear rules so that when I'm
in the minority I'm able to voice my
opinion
and so it's one of the few things that
both sides of the political Spectrum
agree on the only people who don't or
the the people way over on the right
that I call the fascists and the people
way over on the left who are the
Communists
um but with respect to most people in
this on the political Spectrum
Republicans Democrats socialists
Libertarians
um
they agree on the Primacy of free speech
because it protects them
when when protection is needed so to you
even on the internet
Free Speech absolutism should rule yes
nobody's gonna die remember the death
threats are not law not protected
nobody's gonna die
so people are going to be a little bit
insulted that's the price you pay for
living in a free society and it's a
small price in my view
um people some people don't have as
tough a hide as others well then develop
it um
yeah I hope everyone I don't mean to
sound cruel
um but you know you're living in a free
Society develop a tough hide
so that's the cost of living in a free
Society there's a cost the thing is that
it can really hurt at scale to be Cyber
Bullied to be attacked for the ideas to
express or maybe ideas you didn't
Express but that uh somebody decided to
lie about you and uh use that to attack
you well first of all there are there
were so there were some exceptions to
the First Amendment
libel and slander is an exception
um
direct threats or an exception you know
if you if you say such and such I will
murder you that is not lawful
if you say that it's somebody
um if you say about somebody oh you know
um you beat your wife
um that that is not lawful if in fact
the person knows you don't beat your
wife
there are some limits the defamation is
one direct threats or another
um so it's not absolute this is not the
first amendment is not absolute but this
is it's more absolute than it is in any
other society and it's pretty near
absolute
um
for example fraud if you would sell
somebody a car and you say oh this is in
great running shape and in fact it's an
old jalopy and it's not going to make it
more than 10 miles
that's fraud that's not free speech
um so free speech is not absolute there
are these limits but they're very narrow
specific categories of limits
but uh this gray area here because while
legally you're not allowed to defame a
person
in the court of public opinion
especially with the aid of anonymity on
the internet
the rumors can spread
at scale thousands hundreds of thousands
of people can make up things about you
you have to defend yourself using more
speech we're we're big we're through
freedom of speech and we're big boys and
girls
um you have to defend yourself
um you know in in some societies if you
say something
um if you right now if you say something
nasty about Putin you'll end up in the
gulag
um if you say something nasty about
um you know Biden you end up in the New
York Times where would you rather be